two-thirds of pet owners now share a bed
with their cat or dog a new poll
suggests the survey of 2 000 people by
Sleep Brands Silent Night also
discovered that nearly one-third do so
every single night but should we really
be letting uh dogs share our beds while
exposure to mites from pets can
strengthen the immune system experts say
The Habit can run the risk of serious
infection sharing your bed with your dog
increases the chance of them
transferring microbes that sit on a
dog's skin possibly via licking feces or
from their fur such bugs can cause
conditions including mange or even Lyme
disease you can get mange okay you could
become a mangy Beast just like your dog
Professor Alejandra parati a mic expert
at the school of biological sciences
says if a dog owner is immuno Con
immunocompromised or has a weak immune
system even temporarily then they should
not share their bed with a dog yeah if
you're immune a compromise you shouldn't
Sherry by the dark also if you have any
dignity at all as a human being you
shouldn't share your bed with a dog